donald trump never stopped raising funds
from his supporters after the 2020
presidential race
meanwhile his companies continue to
charge his political outfits for goods
and services
as a result the former president has
been able to convert about 1.3 million
dollars of donor money into business
revenue since the 2020 election
according to a review of the latest
federal filings much of the money came
via trump's official campaign committee
donald j trump for president inc in the
months immediately following the
election between the election and the
end of 2020 trump's campaign committee
handed over 113 thousand dollars to
trump's businesses in december 2020 the
committee paid two 38 thousand dollar
rent payments to trump tower commercial
llc the entity through which the former
president owns space inside trump tower
the committee also made two payments of
three thousand dollars at about the same
time to an entity called trump
restaurants llc in the new year trump
didn't really shut down his campaign
committee instead he renamed it turning
it into the make america great again
pack in january 2021 the pack started
funneling money to the trump
organization handing eight thousand
dollars to the trump hotel collection
the group also wrote rent checks to the
same entities that the campaign had been
previously paying thirty 38 000 to trump
tower commercial llc every month or so
and often another three thousand dollars
to trump restaurants llc
by the end of february 2022 the make
america great again pack had paid
526 thousand dollars to trump's
companies according to the review of
federal election commission filings it's
unclear why the make america great again
pacs still needed to pay hundreds of
thousands of dollars of rent in 2021
given that the election took place in
2020 representatives of the pac and the
trump organization did not respond to
requests for comment there's also
trump's leadership pack save america
leadership packs often allow politicians
to dole out money to other candidates
they support
in trump's case the group also served as
a vehicle for directing donor money into
his businesses from february 2021 to may
2022 trump's leadership pac spent 213
thousand dollars at trump properties
the save america payments generated some
press recently as the select committee
to investigate the january 6 attack on
the united states capital took note of
the group's operations the former
president told supporters that they
could donate to something called the
official election defense fund even
though that fund apparently didn't exist
according to the committee
most of the money instead went to save
america which in turn paid a small
portion to trump's businesses